it's easy to find yourself throwing
through endless titles on Netflix
without ever picking anything but that
doesn't mean the streaming platform has
nothing good to offer you just need to
know where to look if you're in the mood
for a good action movie you haven't seen
a million times
here are some hidden gems waiting for
you on Netflix 13 assassins if you're a
fan of audition or Ichi the Killer
here's another classic action movie from
takashi miike 13 assassins is less
brutal than those earlier films but was
favorably compared to Seven Samurai
which is about the highest praise a
samurai film can get taking place near
the sunset of feudal Japan a group of
samurai gather together to defeat a
sinister Lord before he takes the throne
with a 96% rating on Rotten Tomatoes
this might become a new action favorite
Big Trouble in Little China it's hard to
go wrong with an 80s action movie
starring Kurt Russell Big Trouble in
Little China stars Russell as Jack
Burton a man who goes into the mythical
underworld of Chinatown to save a green
eyed damsel the movie has tons of humor
and great 80s action if you like John
Carpenter film especially Escape from
New York you'll wonder why it's taken
you so long to watch Big Trouble in
Little China plus it features a great TV
theme song from John Carpenter's ban
what's not to love
deja vu Tony Scott didn't always get as
much praise as his older brother Ridley
but he brought us some fantastic films
the man behind True Lies in the 80s
tabletop gun got together an a-list cast
for the 2006 film déjà vu an underrated
film that Netflix has been hiding right
under your nose Denzel Washington stars
as Doug Carlin and investigator cast
with solving a deadly bombing in New
Orleans he's given a new piece of
technology that can gaze back for days
into the past to help with the
investigation but he becomes obsessed
with the idea of actually traveling
through time to stop the tragic event
from happening it's a little sci-fi a
little action and all awesome the hunter
ever wanted to watch willem dafoe hunt
for an extinct tiger in the wilds of
tasmania well the hunter has just made
your dreams come true
this unusual action film combines
science exotic locales and rich
character depths to create a really
intriguing action movie
if you're looking for a slower pace but
extremely well acted action adventure
the hunter is just the ticket lucky
number Slevin this quirky crime comedy
flew under the radar on its release but
lucky number Slevin is full of twists
turns and distracting funds that'll keep
you watching to the end it's clever
funny and has an amazing cast that
includes Morgan Freeman Bruce Willis
Lucy Liu and Ben Kingsley with a clever
script and slick visual style lucky
number Slevin is surprisingly
entertaining
the finest hours based on a true story
the tale of a daring 1952 Coast Guard
rescue received some pretty positive
reviews but kind of sank after its
initial release maybe because the finest
hours is pretty generic for a title but
this real-life tale starring Star Trek's
Chris Pine is full of thrilling moments
and moving drama so before the finest
hours slipped from your memory again
give this fine historical drama a try
alive this gripping drama is based on
the true story of a Uruguayan rugby team
struggling to survive in the Andes after
a plane crash after only twenty-five
people lived through the initial
accident the team members have to resort
to desperate measures to stay alive if
you haven't already guessed yes this is
the movie where the survivors end up
eating each other but it's not a horror
film watching these people grasp at hope
through the very worst conditions is
harrowing and although the movie sounds
kind of depressing is actually an
uplifting tale of survival and the
unbelievable strength of mankind not to
mention a roller coaster ride of sheer
adrenaline sufers just in case two
installments of guardians of the galaxy
wasn't enough to satisfy your love of
james gunn films netflix has a classic
waiting for you before you watch super
guns for a superhero film you should
know that it's a dark comedy very dark
that said it's definitely a visually
unique take on superheroes starring
Rainn Wilson and Ellen Page super is
about a man who decides to dress up as a
superhero to save his ex-wife who
doesn't really want to be saved it may
not have the budget of guardians but you
can see Gunn's flair for action and
irreverent humor shine through troll
hunter this surprisingly unique film
follows a group of
people on a quest to find real trolls in
the frozen tundra of Norway after they
find out that the existence of trolls
has been covered up by the Norwegian
government they make it their duty to
capture one of the elusive monsters on
film this is no troll sue these trolls
look amazing and don't have to turn
humans into plans to eat them shot like
a documentary the film is often
hilarious though not without its tense
moments moira macdonald film critic at
The Seattle Times wrote those fog drapes
fjords provide a distractingly pretty
backdrop to this tale of mysterious
massive creatures who roam the forests
by night searching for Christians on
whom to munch it's safe to say that
you're not going to find a better movie
about massive monsters eating religious
folks zombeavers don't worry zombie
earth is completely aware that it's a
movie about zombie beavers thankfully
it's a fun horror parody that makes the
idea of undead beavers as funny as it
could possibly be critic Tim Brighton
called it the funniest horror comedy
since at the very least the cabin in the
woods if you want a campy diverting
comedy that's full of laughs and
gross-out gags zombeavers is exactly
what you're looking for welcome to the
punch starring mark Strong and James
McAvoy as a criminal and cop who team
ups you uncover a conspiracy
welcome to the plunge is straight-up
action in the best possible way the
solid casting choices lend a bit of
seriousness and depth of character to
the storage but let's all be honest this
is a movie you watch for often change
scenes and gun fights welcome to the
punch is pretty violence but you'd
probably expect that from a film that
invites you to a beating in the title
last night a cast that stars Clive Owen
and Morgan Freeman usually means a movie
worth watching add in castles swords and
revenge and you have yourself a fine
action film now the critics weren't
especially kind to last night but the
New York Times thought bonnie-and-clyde
was an overly violent pointless piece of
cinema but why listened to critics last
night's probably won't stand the test of
time like Bonnie and Clyde
but it's Game of Thrones reruns aren't
doing it for you or if you just like
hearing the soothing tones of Morgan
Freeman while people are killed with
swords slash sights is worth a watch
thanks for watching click the
four icons to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]